We want to create our neural network.
So let me
Write the code first.
I will then take you to the slide to show you.
the picture of the architecture
and then I'll show you the
The Matrix operation we call convolution
So this is going to be called.
building the
neural network model
so we will instantiate the sequential class like we
saw in the previous notebook.
again, because we again because we are critic a
sequence of
layers input layers and layers output
layer
of course, we can stack onto this network other types
of layers, but we're just going to have
we will have two convolutional layers three convolution layers.
two Max pooling layers
One Flat layer
and
two dense layers
What are these we'll see in a minute.
So we have the input layer. We have
one con 2D layer
all by a Max pool layer.
And we will do this three times flat layer and
two dance layers. This is the architecture.
Let me show you a picture of it.